Stephen is in Houston Texas hey Stephen
how are you hey Dave I'm doing great how
about yourself better than I deserve
what's up
oh man I'm doing good I had a question
well I wanted to know I'm completely out
of debt and I want to know your opinion
on saving up a 20% down payment on a
house while living with my parents I
wouldn't okay what do you make a year
forty thousand older I'm 20 23 okay I
Stephen my experiences this I mean I've
got my youngest is 25 my oldest is 30
and married okay so um you know your
contemporary of my kids in other words
age wise my experience with them has
been this I didn't want them to move out
of house I love them and we have good
relationship and having them hang out at
the house as a fine thing it didn't
bother me a bit
okay in the sense of relationally I
wasn't trying to boot them out but what
did occur when they moved out and they
didn't move out at your age
and they got their own place was there
was something that they walked a little
bit straighter there's a dignity to
having your own deal and there's a one
last notch in the emotional evolution or
emotional mature maturation process that
happens when you know that that
apartment or that house you're renting
with some buddies or whatever it is
you've got to pay the lights or they get
cut off you've got to take the garbage
out or piles up you know it's your deal
and there's something that happens when
you do that that is really good for
Stephen and it's not that your mom and
dad wouldn't mind having you around I'm
sure you're delightful and I mean it's
not and it's not that you know you
didn't call me up going they're driving
me crazy I got to get out of here you
didn't say that so it's not the you mind
being there but there's just something
else
that's very cool for Steven that happens
when you do it and so I always encourage
parents to boot their 23 year olds out
for that reason yes yeah I was expecting
you say something along those lines you
sound a lot like my parents I don't know
it's not just point being it's not just
a math thing if it was just math you'd
stay there for free and pile up money
right right is no it's a no-brainer the
math part of it because whatever you're
spending on rents money going down the
toilet and you know you're not going to
get that money to put in your pile of
money for your 20% down payment so you
know but it's okay to rent for a little
while and put up with a landlord and put
up with a electric company or cable
company they didn't show up when they're
supposed to which is like all of them
and you know it's okay to do all that
and there's something good for you about
all that so I'm going to recommend you
go ahead and move even though it delays
mathematically your ability to save for
the down payment a little bit the weird
thing is I think it all comes out in the
end because I think what happens to you
affects your income in a positive way
that that because you're out there
fighting you're out there in the world I
mean you're out there in the cold
weather so to speak and so yeah that's
that's what I'm going to tell you to do
it's been my experience and it's been a
positive experience thanks for thanks
for joining me sir
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five
that's a sharp young man right there but
to you parents who have that 30 year old
that 28 year old living in your basement
sitting on their butt growing in the
downstairs couch like a toadstool you're
an enabler and you're destroying our
society by allowing these little guys to
sit on their butts kick them out you're
killing manhood in our culture this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]